I rely on one of my favorite political
philosophers I know he's somebody you've
drawn a tremendous amount of wisdom as
well Yoda who in the fire strikes back
on his training Luke and Decker but you
were maybe going John Lockwood much more
profound than that he's a property very
important but Yoda when he's training
yeah yeah and so at one point when he's
training Luke he says you must unlearn
what you have learned you guys have
different rules depending on the medium
how how sort of complicated is that
these days you've put your finger on one
of the central problems in
communications policy is that Congress
sets the law and that law reflects a
snapshot of the marketplace in a moment
in time and that stops snapshot
especially in the technology sector very
quickly becomes yellowed with age and so
we hear constantly for example from
broadcast TV companies saying look we're
competing the same space with Google and
Facebook and other companies who don't
face the same we're like legacy
regulations that we have to deal with
you need to change that and different
sectors of the economy say the same
thing there's always the problem of
government trying to fit the square peg
of the marketplace into the round hole
of the law so what do you say to those
guys when they say that cuz that's a
pretty compelling argument I think I
mean sometimes now you watch yeah like
we have regulations on what commercials
could say be on television versus the
Internet
yeah much anything could be out there so
the way I think about it the one thing I
told my team from the beginning and I've
told them every day sense is think about
where the marketplace is right now how
would you construct a regulatory
framework to deal with the marketplace
as it stands today and to the maximum
extent permitted by law we should adjust
our regulations modernize them to
reflect that marketplace and I rely on
one of my favorite political
philosophers I know he's somebody you've
drawn a tremendous amount of wisdom as
well Yoda who in the Empire Strikes Back
was training Luke and DeCoteau you were
made to go in John Lockwood much more
profound than not to be property very
important but Yoda when he's training
yeah and so at one point when he's
training Luke he says you must unlearn
what you have learned and that is so
true when it comes to Washington the
regulatory impulse is so strong when you
see an uber or a lift oh that's a
taxicab company let's let's lap all the
taxicab regulations on it Airbnb oh
that's a hotel company same thing in the
telecom sector too
let's try to make sure horn all these
legacy regulations onto these new
companies and to maintain those
regulations on the established companies
my goal is pretty simple to just
modernize our regulations to reflect the
marketplace we're in unlearn what you
have learned when it comes to telecom
policy and you'll unleash all kinds of
innovation and investment that
ultimately benefits consumers we don't
want to dis incentivize companies from
competing and innovating because
ultimately the consumer welfare the
consumer Wolfers what's at stake here
more importantly than any of this where
we're yet with the new Star Wars yeah so
this high I haven't really been a big
fan except for I will say I thought
force awakens was okay that's for rogue
one yeah that was awesome every day I
need more force really yeah I didn't
seen those I mean it really feeds into
that for scene in the episode four and
it's but no force awakens was pretty
good I thought so well you give me two
hours of the last five minutes of rogue
one two hours of just an onslaught then
I'm thrilled but alright lost their
because I sense we could probably do
that for for a couple hours so a lot of
this is sort of just fighting the
Washington machine right like John the
machine itself is designed to create
regulation right so they see something
like uber come out now everyone loves
uber and it's changing the business but
now you've got all these interests with
the taxi companies and then suddenly you
then have to fight the impulse to yeah
basically crush them - yeah that that's
a pretty amazing position here it's very
difficult and there are two very
powerful forces in Washington one is
regulatory inertia that it's very easy
to maintain the rules on the books
because they've always been on the books
and they should always therefore be on
the books but the other one is some of
the entrenched interests that say look
no matter any regulatory change is going
to disadvantage somebody and so they
will complain those people who are
affected will have a disproportionate
voice they'll be very loud about it and
so that's part of the challenge as well
to try to have the long term value of
the greater number of people in mind
when we make our decisions so let's talk
about that a little bit like the the
lobbying situation how much of the
influence that hits you is lobbyists
from either telecommunications companies
or free speech organizations or whatever
it might be yeah every sector I think
has
has a grievance or to share with the
agency but our goal is just a little bit
about how it works so you're in your
office your son says D all right you got
a couple meetings today and now you know
some lobbyists are coming in like what
what is the process actually like so
yeah I have a lot of meetings every day
that I'm in the office in Washington and
what often happens is that people will
sit on my couch very much like we're
sitting here and what they'll tell me oh
gee you're doing a great job on this and
that and this and that we are all in
favor of this we are big free market
advocates on this particular issue week
it's amazing how many times that happens
I've needed a roundtable recently on the
road and it was striking one of the
biggest innovations we've introduced we
have a ten billion dollar subsidy fund
known as the Universal Service Fund
typically this consisted of cutting
checks to rural telephone companies and
saying your vaio can do as we hope you
build broadband networks with this
funding one of the major innovations I
introduced about two years ago when I
just got on board was instead of just
cutting a check let's have an auction a
reverse auction where all kinds of
companies using technologies have to
compete for this funding and there's a
downward pressure on prices it's
technologically neutral saves the
taxpayer money Yatta Yatta it much more
efficient at serving the cause I can sit
in this roundtable they said we love all
of the stuff you're doing on the
Universal Service Fund it might be
helpful though to court me to exempt us
from the auction mechanism because it'd
just be because look I understand from
their business perspective it makes
sense but my goal it can't be to
vindicate any private interest it is not
to vindicate any private interest it's
to uphold the public interest and that's
going to make people unhappy in many
cases because many business plans might
not survive or might not thrive in an
environment where that kind of
competition is embraced by the regulator
so let's back up a little bit to your
philosophy again which basically you're
saying free markets you want them to do
as much as possible yeah you're the guy
that has to come in and give some
regulation around the public good what
do you think would happen so this maybe
is this is like sort of the the purist
libertarian approach what do you think
would happen if you just basically the
regulation sister all disappeared and
just the free market just was allowed to
do whatever whatever it wants related to
all of these issues around communication
like what questionably would happen I
think it's that's a very good question
so any I'm gonna move this because
otherwise
if we leave this the entire time the
amount of memes that will come out that
you had an hour-long conversation with a
recess bar on the table oh my god it's
gonna it's become the MacGuffin already
the area for those film buffs out there
you can have it later
you promise well let's just see how it
finishes okay all right we'll see how it
goes but but your question was about the
lack of regulation altogether and I'm
not one who says necessarily that we
need to scrap everything for example in
terms of setting spectrum policy it's
important for us to coordinate among
different government agencies in the
private sector
but I do think that it would be an
interesting experiment some of these
areas of the government got out of the
business give you one example back in
1975 one of my predecessors instituted
rule prohibiting newspapers and
broadcast TV and radio stations from
combining because that was seem to be
detrimental to competition does anyone
really think in 2019 that local
newspapers local radio stations are the
dominant force in any particular market
especially some of the smaller markets I
mean I don't really think so so if we
got rid of regulations there I don't
think it would lead to all this
consolidation to the contrary it would
enable them to compete with the googles
and the Facebook's and the Pandora's and
Spotify and others who are out there
distributing information and so to me at
least I think it's an interesting
thought exercise and as that denominator
so to speak grows as more people start
to compete in the same space I think
it's important for government to have an
intellectually honest assessment of what
competition is that denominator is much
broader than broadcast radio for example
it's all those streaming services and
podcasts and all the rest of it that
people the people just want to consume
information information honestly is the
denominator in many cases so I I think
there's probably certain amount if you
were listening to this code all right
he's down with the free markets he's
writing is the light touch when possible
yeah how was this guy nominated by Obama
this sounds more like say a conservative
or a Republican approach can you talk
about that yeah so traditionally
commissioners who are in the minority so
the FCC I should have backed up the five
commissioners I mentioned three of whom
are of the president's party two are of
the minority party the party had to
power so I was nominated in 2011
confirmed in 2012 for one of the
minority party seats and by tradition
going back a couple of decades the
leader of the part of the Senate leader
of the party out of power it makes a
recommendation to the White House on who
those minority commissioners should be
and so in my case
Senator McConnell recommended to
President Obama we will recommend a
cheat for this slot so my bill has to
say it's okay even though you're the
ones getting the minority slot right
interesting yeah so it's a very
interesting still has the power to stop
that minority person theoretically yes
so unfortunately I fell through the
cracks said yeah I had good friends on
both sides of the aisle and I confirm
unanimously so it wasn't an issue but
it's a very interesting model of
governance and I think of a lot of the
cabinet departments of course which is
just a secretary have a very different
model where it's more of a single person
in charge of the agency so how much then
of your job is coordinating with the
president I mean two things really so
I'm from what I can understand it sounds
like Trump is probably more in line with
your your philosophy around this but
does that even matter that much did you
see a big difference from when Obama was
there to know so that's an interesting
point we are actually an independent
agency so once we are confirmed by the
Senate we're off to the races we don't
answer to anybody we are independent
from the administration independent from
Congress although we of course I assume
they can create headaches for you oh
absolutely and there are certain issues
especially when it comes to security for
example or some spectrum issues where we
have to coordinate with say the
Department of Defense or the National
Security Council where we do work with
White House and administration agencies
all the time but one of the things that
the president-elect told me when I
interviewed for the job in January 2017
was I'm giving you this job because I
believe you're going to do a terrific
things do the job you know I'm trusting
you with this responsibility because I
know you'll execute as you see fit and
we'll back you up 100% of the way and so
that's been largely what it's all been
about we've been pursuing a lot of
different initiatives and they've been
supportive as especially on things like
5g where we think it's a national
priority not just an FCC priority for
America to lead the world in this
next-generation technology if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell